françois poulet mathis merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors une
réunion extraordinaire du conseil
européen se tient demain quels seront
les enjeux principaux de ce sommet c'est
le départ du président loukachenko
ben si tu ne savais pas du tout évident
parce que d'abord les les vingt-sept ne
sont pas complètement sur la même
longueur d'ondés pays comme la hongrie
de viktor orban qui soutenaient plutôt
loukachenko aurait tendance à faire
opposition
mais il ya une réalité tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire la situation de ces
élections les vues surtout les violences
qui ont été commises à l'issue des
élections nécessite une réaction forte
donc on peut penser que cette réaction
sera forte peine sera forte et mesuré
mesuré car les vingt-sept de bob ne
veulent pas pénaliser la population aux
biélorusses ils veulent pénaliser
surtout le dictateur ce qui celui qui
pour est un dictateur c'est à dire
alexandre loukachenko pas ce qui est
particulièrement difficile pour les 27
c'est de coordonner leurs réactions avec
celles de la russie
car dans cette affaire autant les
européens que les russes ont une action
déterminante à jouer les russes encore
plus dans la mesure où vous la dire
poutine a une position qui sera
déterminante
alors justement françois poulet mathis
de posture à vladimir poutine s'est
entretenu avec emmanuel macron par
téléphone le président russe lui juge
inacceptable toute ingérence de son côté
le président français appelle son
homologue russe à favoriser l'apaisement
et le dialogue alors qu'est ce qu'on
peut comprendre à sa vers ces mots de la
posture diplomatique des deux chefs
d'état
c'est des postures diplomatiques comme
vous le dites vous même au delà des
déclarations la question est de savoir
si véritablement vladimir poutine va
soutenir jusqu'au bout
alexandre loukachenko mais le problème
de la dernière usine comme celui
d'ailleurs des européens c'est de mieux
cerner cette opposition qui pour
l'instant n'est pas prêt sernam
on n'est pas dans la situation de
l'ukraine par exemple où il y avait une
forte opposition trop occidentale pro
union européenne là c'est un mouvement
tout à fait un difficile à maîtriser
essentiellement menées par les femmes
les femmes
posant qui ont été arrêtés et c'est un
mouvement qui réclame avant tout la
démission le départ d'alexandre
loukachenko
mais c'est un mouvement qui ne savent
firme ni anti russe ni anti union
européenne
c'est en ça que c'est très difficile
d'adopter une attitude de très clair
aussi faire pour vladimir poutine
d'ailleurs qu'ils ne maîtrisent pas plus
l'opposition biélorusse que les 27 pays
membres de l'union européenne
il s'agira donc de mieux cerner cette
opposition de savoir s'il a une
crédibilité pour savoir en se
coordonnant sans dire sans me dire bien
sûr en se coordonnant avec les russes
pour savoir est ce qu'on la joue est ce
qu'on ne lâche pas alexandre loukachenko
alors l'europe
sk une position commune sur ce sujet
s'il ya un consensus ou alors de
profondes divisions au sein des
vingt-sept
non il n'y a pas de consensus complet
dans la mesure où je le disais au début
de cette interview la hongrie de viktor
orban a soutenu pendant un certain temps
victor loukachenko alexandre loukachenko
mai mais il y a certainement une
unanimité pour considérer que les
violences notamment qui ont été commises
après l'élection était totalement
inadmissible et rien que pour ces
violences il faut qu'il y ait un geste
des sanctions ces sanctions ne seront
pas des sanctions économiques
probablement pas c'est des sanctions qui
visent ont des personnalités qui on
interdira par exemple l'accès à l'union
européenne
c'est essentiellement des des sanctions
et persona et non pas des champions qui
risquerait de toucher la population
biélorusse alors que représente la
biélorussie au fond pour les européens
c'est un partenaire et pour qui ou c'est
un territoire qui est davantage
stratégique à l'est
c'est un territoire qui est stratégique
on le sait pour la russie c'est un
territoire tampon qui est
stratégiquement important pour la russie
mais pour l'union européenne cette arme
pays qui pourraient être importants mais
qui n'a jamais joué de cartes
véritablement européenne il faut
préciser que lorsque la biélorussie est
devenue indépendante elle a conservé
toutes les apparences d'une république
soviétique
avec tous les outils de la répression
c'est le seul pays de l'ex-union ce l'ex
union soviétique qui a gardé par exemple
le cas j'ai une véritable police
politique
c'est le seul pays qui ne fait pas
membres qui n'est pas membre du conseil
de l'europe alors que la russie fait
partie du conseil de l'europe
donc cette api sur laquelle on peut
difficilement se baser c'est aussi vrai
pour les vingt-sept dire que pour
vladimir poutine qui s'est toujours
méfié de son collègue loukachenko merci
beaucoup françois poulet mathis d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste et spécialiste des
institutions européennes